Carrie somehow decided he's a gadget
expert okay
this is Gary talking about gadgets on
the hall-door show here to talk about
the rollicking pace of technological
change from the way you watch movies to
the way we read books I'm joined by the
cw's gadget Gary he's a featured
columnist for sound and vision magazine
he is in reality Baba Booey the
executive producer of the Howard Stern
Show my friend Gary Dell'Abate to see
her oh thanks thanks for coming yes so
if you say you're a an expert and then
you get on to CW 11 and a [ __ ] although
you were an expert listen to this guy
doesn't matter what you know is the iPad
another breakthrough for Apple I don't
know that it's a breakthrough for them I
in fact I think in a lot of ways it was
a bit of a stumble for them I think it's
gonna be a great product I think they're
gonna sell a ton of them but they've had
two home runs in a row that hasn't why
is that a stumble but they're not gonna
sell the amount that they thought they
were gonna sell the iPhone and the iPod
those are amazing so people were
expecting something unbelievable
something that I don't think that they
could put together so there's a lot of
things that are missing from the iPad
that I hear people talking about that
they say or a deal breaker but for me
I'm trying to figure out well who's it
for in other words if I have to hear my
pocket I have an iPhone right so if I
have this the iPad is a bigger version
of this so if I have this why am I gonna
pay 800 bucks for that and another $30 a
month confuse the iPad is for people who
want to carry a laptop at a light laptop
but it's not a laptop that's the problem
doesn't do anything that a laptop does
sure does plain what he answers his own
dumb question all right you're obsessed
he started it clearly Ralph has watches
more than one hood but waited around for
it my kids have the eye touch and they
set the back of my car and they watch
movies on it I look at that I go I can't
look at a movie I can't even see what's
going on there but as they get older and
as we get older and die away maybe the
books will die away and maybe that'll be
the way that they do things you explain
on the little iPhone how you can't see a
movie so this thing would be perfect for
you I said I don't know exactly who this
is for if I own this why am I gonna buy
another device you just answered your
question it's $800 right right so now I
have to spend another
another $30 a month at $500 it depends
on which one you get Ralph well all
right your gadget Gary thing is catching
on whether we like it or not you are
becoming gadget Gary and people are
turning right at the national show
FoxNews Geraldo people just kid you see
them on TV doesn't mean they know
anything what do you know I know a lot
no I just say I know that you know
nothing about candidates bad hey
whatever and you really really [ __ ] you